nous sommes à l'établissement de
détention provincial de saint jérôme
depuis des mois ces hommes sont dans la
tente d'un repas très particulier ce
qu'ils appellent le festin 39,4 aux mots
puis j'avais déjà prochaine
[Musique]
tania patrick lussier et les autres 19
détenus d'origine inuit des hommes qui
ont accepté d'ouvrir une porte sur leurs
cultures culinaires à visage découvert
[Musique]
une semaine plus tôt au petit matin un
avion quitte le nunavik avec à son bord
une précieuse cargaison destinée ou dit
nous on fait pas mal toutes les piles
tension au québec qu'on voit dans la
cale à la macaza on va à mosport
quartier on a beaucoup dans la région
sont à laval andré pomerleau a grandi au
nunavik dans le grand nord québécois
c'est lui qui commande les victuailles
aux chasseurs et pêcheurs inuits et les
livres ou du raisonnement jusqu'au bout
de pau vont bientôt gillard tchad car
seuls trois juges de la balle un qui a
été pris à coups de joueurs qu avec les
voit présentement je veux aller chez
elle le boucher puis lui aurait coupé
sera petites tranches pour pour manger
ce cru
marc cloutier est un beau chic
spécialisé en coupes de viande sauvage
le caribou la peau et le gras de baleine
le fameux mark tuck et le béluga compte
parmi les sources de protéines préféré
des i know it
oui oui si on a du caribou les épaules
des bassins est second poteau de couper
en morceaux et remarques ce morceau a
passé son nom du maroc et du grog
baleine avec la poupe d'anan dessus on
voit juste orient six morceaux puis ça
c'est des nageoires de béluga qu'on va
trancher aussi à passer en avant pour
mâles tranché jusqu'au complet
[Musique]
ils sont autour du poisson oui j'en ai
un qui me regardez pas l'interet comme
l'artichaut de l'homme de l'art ti et ça
ça vient de quelle région celui du
nunavik en eau
l'omble de l'arctique appelé aussi omble
chevalier fait partie des habitudes
alimentaires traditionnels des inuits
c'est un poisson qui ferait dans les
eaux du nord du québec
long de l'article quand vous allez le
préparer ça va se faire comme mais on va
le prendre au mot le pc a6 à partir du
but inné jusqu'à l'arrêt nord joueurs
hissent en arrière tout en petites
rondelles pour mais ça dans un sac ou
dans une boîte
quelques jours plus tard la nourriture
arrive que monsieur et vous qu'il est je
ferai la boîte on a le mode path qui est
la grotte balle un sabre à des petits
morceaux fonctionne pour en plus marcher
comme il faut andré pomerleau oued
justin à thème et son équipe du centre
de détention a complété le travail du
boucher afin que tous les détenus louit
aient droit à leur part avec les blacks
maintenant quand vous voyez c'est pas
évident parce que c'est vraiment très
joli record qu'on fait notre mieux avec
ce corner on n'a pas le droit de deux
dispositifs d'instruments métal ici
venant pour des raisons de sécurité donc
on y va avec les moyens du bord excédé
couteau en plastique
c'est enfin l'heure du festin
le caissier et christina deux aînés du
nunavik ont parcouru 1400 kilomètres en
avion pour offrir leur enseignement et
animer le repas c'est en moyenne 4 à 5
fois par année on a droit à cette
[Musique]
cette façon de manger ici en prison
c'est exactement ce qui se fait
traditionnellement à la maison malick
tall au même
nous on attend qu'un que les années sans
vie non on est content parce qu'on sait
qu'on hommage comment ces différents que
vous avez maintenant vers 6 la
nourriture que vous mangez
habituellement c'est de bien plus de
protéines tapas fin avril
kraft foods pour accompagner cette
nourriture gelé smith irak qui est en
fait du gras de mammifères marins comme
du phoque de la baleine ou du béluga
qu'on laisse fermenter et qui devient
une huile servant de sauce ou de
condiments oui
mais les aliments gras mais la tradition
inuit
c'est aussi de manger en groupe
comment n'y aurait eu que nous reculer
le niveau que je leur ai dit comme ça
mais les 904 est très très loin de leur
milieu d'appartenance est vraiment
déracinement qui est associé à ce donc
voilà ça sert à maintenir les liens avec
un milieu avec leur culture dos brûlures
de poules louiic going up datsun
demi-finale à l'acte à noter pour
terminer ce repas inuit un thé
accompagné de pagnes kita 1p banic
traditionnel à base de farine de sel de
saindoux et d'eau
[Musique]
baby food inc un festin qui nourrit le
corps mais aussi l'esprit c'est angie
est ce qu'il faut le palet discus veille
ce qui est des gens qui travaillent
habitations ou des centres de détention
absolument son sont contentes du service
qu'on apporte et parce que les gens sont
plus calmes plus heureux ils ont eu un
peu de chez eux c'est sûr c'est pas le
milieu les plus chaleureux le milieu
carcéral
je pense que de manger entre eux ça leur
permet peut-être de d'oublier pendant un
instant où est-ce qu'ils sont déçus
retrouve un groupe de partager un repas
avec les années je pense que ça met un
petit peu rebondi sur le fait juste
d'être privée la liberté mais aussi loin
de leur milieu
coupez la culture